welcome back everybody to the David
Pacman show my name is Luke Beasley I'm
going to be filling in for David today
while he is away on paternity leave
obviously exciting stuff going on huge
congratulations to David and his family
we have a massive show to get into so
let's Dive Right In last night the
January 6th committee held their first
big public hearing where they started
the process of going through all the
information they have gathered over the
last number of months and I thought that
the chairman Congressman Thompson as
well as Liz Cheney who kind of led the
presentation for the night did a really
good job of outlining a few main points
so we're gonna do a bird's eye view look
at these main points and then we're
going to dive into some specific moments
the first is Donald Trump was absolutely
supportive and they made this very clear
of the rioters he was watching it unfold
and he was supportive of it and as we're
going to get into in just a second he
was even
cheering on supportive of the rioters
who wanted to kill his own vice
president
the second big thing was he absolutely
was told by people close to him
repeatedly that the claims he was making
were false I think we had all kind of
assumed that but that was shown as well
people like former Attorney General
William Barr and his own daughter Ivanka
Trump were aware that the election was
not stolen there's no evidence for that
and yet Trump kept perpetuating it
the third big thing was there was a
clear and planned coordinated effort
to attack the capital by the proud boys
and The Oath Keepers and the reason why
I say that is because there was some
question of was it just a protest that
got out of hand or was it a premeditated
event by some people and at least in the
case of The Proud boys and The Oath
Keepers it was premeditated and that's a
big deal the fourth big thing and this
is the most important part of all of
this is Donald Trump was the first U.S
president in all of our history to not
respect the peaceful transition of power
and that is huge because that is
absolutely necessary to holding together
our democracy and he just spit all over
it
because he was just upset he lost an
election
he stomped on our entire history of
doing a really good job
the person who's in power if they lose
they respectfully exit and do what they
can to make it a peaceful transition and
so
that put our democracy in Peril and
that's a huge point we have to keep
stating so that everyone does not forget
it obviously these videos can't be super
super long so I can't go through
everything that I would want to
um from this hearing because there was a
lot jam-packed into it the stuff that I
can't cover I'll try to get to some of
it on my own show so you can find that
at Luke Beasley on YouTube if you're
watching this on YouTube or listening to
the podcast it'll be in the description
box a link to my channel but definitely
check out my show Luke Beasley on
YouTube but I also encourage you to
watch the whole hearing if you haven't
already yourself because there's tons of
stuff they're super super important for
you to be aware of that came out of that
hearing
so the first humongous bombshell
that came out of this hearing
was it was exposed that Donald Trump was
supportive of the rioters who were
chanting hang Mike Pence he was made
aware that that was happening
and he was supportive of it
let's take a look
and aware of the rioter's chance to hang
Mike Pence the president responded with
this sentiment quote maybe our
supporters have the right idea
Mike Pence quote deserves it I know
because there's already been coverage of
a lot of this and you've probably
already run it through your head you can
get a little numbed out to it but really
think about this the president of the
United States was supportive of a mob of
people who wanted to murder his vice
president you would watch that a movie
like that's not even something
that would be fiction right if you ever
heard that type of story it's a
fictional no the president of the United
States wanted his vice president to get
murdered that's what we just watched and
we can't forget that these crazy things
happened or get numbed out to them
the next big thing I want to look at is
William Barr uh Trump's attorney general
testified in a pre-recorded interview
about how he looked into it saw there
was no fraud that would have made any
difference in the election no wide scale
um widespread fraud and then we'll play
the clip of Ivanka who got asked about
Barr's statement and pretty much said
yeah I mean
if Barr said it like I believe it so
pretty much I don't agree with my dad's
statements let's take a look uh told the
president in no uncertain terms that I
did not see evidence of fraud uh
and you know that would have affected
the outcome of the election and frankly
a year and a half later I haven't seen
anything to to change my mind on that
how did that affect your perspective
about the election when attorney general
Barr made that statement
it affected my perspective
um I respect the Attorney General Barr
so I
accepted what he said was saying
so Donald Trump's attorney general and
his daughter are both well aware and
William Barr told Trump that Trump's
claims were false and yet he kept on
going with them and the amount of damage
that that did if he had stopped at some
point before January 6th and realized
you know what I thought it was stolen
but looks like all the evidence has come
out it wasn't actually stolen we would
have saved so much damage from being
done to our democracy the next big thing
that happened in the hearing was a
documentarian testified under oath and
again I encourage you guys to go watch
this hearing for yourself but I'll give
you a quick summary so the documentarian
had been allowed access in the days
leading up to January 6th and on January
6th to follow around Enrique tario who
is the leader of the proud boys and
throughout that I guess they wanted him
or were okay with him making a
documentary about the organization or
whatever was going on and what he
captured and witnessed throughout that
process proved what I mentioned earlier
that the proud Boys in coordination with
The Oath Keepers had actually planned
the events of that day and were just
executing a plan to attack the capital
we'll look at some clips uh from that
testimony that came out on January 5th
the night before the attack you were
with the head of the proud boys Mr tario
in Washington D.C
what happened
uh we picked up his bags and went to get
some other bags from the Phoenix Hotel
where we
encountered Mr Stewart Rhodes from The
Oath Keepers we drove down into the
parking garage and filmed the scene of
Mr tario and Mr Rhodes and certain other
individuals
in that garage the committee learned
that the Oath Keepers set up quick
reaction forces outside of the city in
Virginia where they stored arms the goal
of these quick reaction forces was to be
on standby just in case president Trump
invoked the Insurrection act did video
Keepers ever provide weapons to members
I'm inclined to answer that I put them
with Browns they're acting as if they're
executing some military operation so
after the documentarian spoke a female
police officer
recounted her experience trying
desperately to defend the capital and
one of the stories she tells she's
holding one of those bike racks that
doubles as a fence and she gets shoved
backwards hits her head on a railing and
then onto the cement and gets knocked
out cold
so she goes through and walks through
that and then walks through the other
traumatizing horrible things that
happened and that she witnessed that day
that kind of brings me to my last big
point on this
my Baseline emotion watching all of this
was just rage at the beginning I thought
about this a lot before but at the
beginning because they pointed out it
was top of mind for me that we have this
long history of peaceful transitions of
power
and while you and I both know some
horrible things have happened in
American history we've failed miserably
in the past many times but the one thing
we got right
was that peaceful transition of power
and it's what kept our democracy alive
and Donald Trump
was willing to let that all
uh die to let Democracy in America die
for his own gain for his own benefit
because he wanted more to believe he won
and to stay in power than just admitting
he lost the election and and moving
along like every other president had
done in the past
that's a fact we cannot let people lose
sight of
That's How Deeply selfish and
narcissistic he is he doesn't care about
the greater good of the country because
if he did he would have realized the
claims he was making were false
and then conceded
and helped to make a trend a peaceful
transition of power but that's not what
he did
I'll be giving more my thoughts on this
on my show again you can find that at
Luke Beasley on YouTube
uh b-e-a-s-l-e-y is how you spell my
last name
um or if you're watching this on YouTube
or listening to the podcast it will be
in the description box a little link you
can click to check me out one of our
sponsors is Crush Organics these guys
are awesome they support the show they
have an excellent collection of premium
grade organic CBD products Crush
Organics has your oils your topical
creams gummies they even have these
great experience gift boxes which are
great for sending to someone this is the
one I received really beautifully
packaged Crush has a daytime CBD blend
in peppermint as well as a nighttime
blend lots of people report CBD being
helpful for Sleep crushes CBD topical
cream can be used on joints and muscles
definitely try the gummies too those are
great Some people prefer the gummies
over the oils Crush Organics care a lot
about quality so you can feel good about
getting your CBD from them they're
always dropping new products pay
attention to this site and crushed
Organics are fans of the David Pacman
show just like you I hope so they're
giving you a massive discount 40 off all
products go to
crushorganics.us and use the code Pacman
to save 40 the link is down below